you are extremely famous in China I am  you're not just you're not just kind of  famous in China  massive in shot I am huge in China  that's so cool yeah I'm and and I did  this movie wolf warrior to which no  one's ever heard of it came out about  two months ago and it's made almost a  billion dollars in China it's incredible  it's one of the most popular movies in  the history it's the second highest  grossing domestic film in the world the  first in China by far and my character  his name is Big Daddy yeah I'm not  kidding this is a true story and I play  the bad American like that you know  China is saving the world from America  and and I'm the bad guy  you're the bad guy yeah hey wait a  minute so you sold us out now have a  clothing line inside again not kidding  yeah it's awesome script my kids all  right  we make it take care themselves  you